bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat got dave here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
absolutely thanks for having me for sure
let's just jump right into your
background
uh you're a lawyer and you work on some
very very innovative industries so we're
going to talk about a whole bunch of
different stuff there but just where'd
you grow up and how did you get into law
yeah so i grew up in aspen colorado
um and uh but basically always wanted
to be a lawyer right up until i was
about to graduate from college
and in quick succession i was like oh
wait no i'm gonna be a doctor oh wait no
i'm gonna be in finance
and so i went to work for merrill lynch
um right during the crisis so we were in
collateral management uh for creative
default swaps in 2008
i knew that lehman was going under like
two weeks before everybody else did
obviously couldn't trade on it um and i
got to watch
the entire thing dissolve from like
backstage it was incredible
um and uh myself and a couple co-workers
found a bunch of errors in merrell's
codes
as they were calculating exposure and
basically over the course of a couple
months
we saved merrell about three and a half
billion dollars in collateral exposure
i was the highest reviewed uh employee
in the office
i got a thousand dollar bonus no raise
uh so i took my three weeks vacation
went back home to aspen and started
studying for the bar exam
i went to law school in 2010
and focused with my finance background
focused on
securities law and intellectual property
graduated securities law intellectual
property is not the biggest
uh practice area in denver colorado um
and so
one of my uh really good friends from
law school nadav ashton who's
actually now my partner was working for
a cannabis firm
uh in denver and there was a firm that
shared office space with his firm that
needed an attorney
i applied for the job and never looked
back uh been in cannabis law ever since
um and that has led to you know hemp law
cbd
law uh and then eventually into crypto
and i can we're going to have all
happened but the
important thing is that when i first
started doing cannabis law
uh the people who were calling
themselves you know corporate marijuana
lawyers were basically just
defense attorneys who had marijuana
clients who were now saying that they
were business attorneys so
with my background i was actually able
to clear out a pretty good
niche pretty quickly uh so much so that
fast forward 2019 i was able to bring uh
nadav ashley the guy who put me in the
cannabis law on
as my partner which was kind of a cool
full circle
uh experience so what's so funny to me
is you start out in cannabis law and a
lot of people don't know how connected
these two industries are right they know
that they're innovative they know that
they are
uh definitely kind of uh you know people
who like to
kind of push the edge of innovation are
attracted to both of them but
most people don't understand that the
cannabis industry is really cut off from
the financial system
and therefore they've had to adopt
bitcoin uh and cryptocurrencies so talk
a little bit about
as you're doing cannabis law how you
come across uh bitcoin and crypto
yeah so um interestingly
totally unrelated is how i got into it
um a good friend of mine
who was in finance and was working in
thailand
called me up and uh started to talk
about
this thing he wanted to do called an ico
and
you know being in the cannabis space
funding is all of my clients are banked
and have been banking since 2017 it's a
common myth but the problem
with the industry is funding because you
cannot get good funding
so he starts to describe this whole ico
thing and my immediate thought was
oh my god we can use this to fund
cannabis companies
um that didn't actually happen but it
was enough to get me
super super motivated to learn the space
um and so basically
for a period in late 2016 early 2017 i'd
wake up at like eight in the morning
i'd work as a cannabis attorney until
about midnight
and then from midnight to maybe two or
three every night i would be
cramming on on what this whole ico boom
was
how crypto worked i mean i bought my
first bitcoin in
2013 and kind of forgot about it for a
bit
uh and as i started doing this i started
to kind of like
sort of digitally follow my buddy around
uh the internet trying to
pick up pieces and then one night i was
like
hey you know what the howie test is
right like he's in finance i assumed he
understood it he had no idea and so i
explained to him like hey
this is very likely to be uh the sale of
securities
and then like literally two days later
there was a big article
studio in hacker noon where someone kind
of explained the howie test
to the masses and the that sort of
relationship flipped and he started to
chase me around uh asking me questions
and uh became general counsel for that
company
uh or outside general counsel um got
involved with
a firm in thailand that is very big in
the
crypto space they flew me out there
and we started doing work for them uh
and then slowly started to bring it back
to our practice here
where uh now can't just stop our
practice uh followed by him but then
blockchain crypto is our third biggest
area and our fastest growing area
um and quite frankly it's one of the
most interesting spaces i've ever been
in
and i'm i'm in some pretty interesting
spaces yeah
and so when you think through kind of
the crypto business uh that you've got
it's fast growing there's lots of
companies that
seem to be popping up every day what
exactly are these clients looking for
when it comes to
legal representation or legal advice
that's a great question they don't know
what they're looking for
um and it's uh it's a very interesting
so
cannabis and crypto are so similar in
one sense but in the other sense they're
very different than that
everyone in cannabis knows they have to
have an attorney they know
that they can't start out without having
good legal counsel because
it's federally illegal and there are
really nuanced components to this
and there's a lot of overlap there but
in the crypto space
these guys are all devs and engineers
and they're
uh they're they're coding the future and
and they kind of
have this blind spot for how slow
regulation works
and how long it takes for these things
to catch up to them
um you know what that initial client
that i was talking about
they were convinced that they didn't
need to have an entity
and i had to walk them through how when
you don't have an entity you have
unlimited liability
personally and they're like no it exists
uh in the ether it's
it's all decentralized like yeah until
someone sues you or sues your group and
then you're all general partners
um and we've seen that a lot recently as
these dow first
uh um organizations have come about and
they have these high minded uh ideas and
believe me i'm
super passionate about it but you know
it's my job to kind of be
chicken little and follow them around
and say you know
this is what could happen this is how
you're exposing yourself
i know you don't want to listen to this
i know you want to move fast
but like if you don't want to go to jail
uh or
you know experience massive civil
liability you have to listen to me
and it's not just an idle thing like we
actually have a client
who was in the uh in the blockchain
space
we weren't only very clear we weren't
advising him on this project
uh he went to jail for uh related to
on the sale of unregistered securities
um so
it's real and the enforcement action
uh you know the investigation started
like five years ago
and it only came to a head in 2019 so
um that's that's the single most
difficult
aspect of this industry is getting the
founders and the
innovators to realize that while we
might get
we will get there someday we will get to
the point where
you know a dow is a is recognized as an
entity
just on its own for example but we're
not there yet
and the the the uh
amount of time that it takes to get
there there's a lot of enforcement that
can happen so that's
that's really that's what we we we do in
the space is uh um
help people apply existing case law
existing
experience in corporate securities law
work in ip work
and we help them uh protect what they've
built
even though they're pushing the limit so
much
so i want to talk a little bit kind of
further down this rabbit hole right of
decentralization i think people who are
listening to the podcast know
it's one of my main focuses moving
forward um is i just think that
centralization is now a business risk
and decentralization
will be the default right and so when we
go down that path
uh that feels like there's not a lot of
precedent when it comes to
the legal system um walk me through
kind of what do we know and kind of what
is precedent in the decentralized world
um and how much of what we're seeing
kind of play out
right now uh will eventually end up
having to
be the case law like there's just
uncharted territory we haven't gone to
court yet over some of this stuff and so
like
there's gonna be kind of those seminal
cases that end up being the precedent
it's just that they haven't happened yet
like just how do you view the
intersection of decentralized
technologies and organizations with the
law
so specifically on decentralization um
i think that uh one we have not seen
any uh cases bought yet
i think we will and i think the way we
will see it is
this um this imputation of a general
partnership
and and what that means and to kind of
and then to explain why that's so
important um if you and i
started like we started a new podcast
scoping so you david and palm
we're just doing stuff we don't put any
corporate form around it's not an llc
it's not a c corp it's not a formalized
partnership
the government imputes what's called a
general partnership
and so you and i are 50 50
equally liable for all of the actions of
our
project of our of our of our partnership
um and that means
all of our assets are completely at risk
if someone sues us and they win
uh for whatever the suit doesn't doesn't
matter what the suit is about
if there's a damages claim we have full
uh liability so over the years
uh you know over the course of you know
from the east india trading company with
the first
actual corporations to the 1980s and
wyoming
with the llc creation we as lawyers have
figured out ways to
limit our liability uh so that just the
company
houses the liability um and i think that
the disregarding of these corporate
forums by some of these
uh decentralized organizations
when you then have a claim against them
for again for whatever reason a lawyer
is going to look at this and they're
going to say
okay there's no corporate form who
is participating what's their
percentages you know
even if there's they're all there's a
hundred of them and they all have one
percent
that's who's gonna get sued that's who's
going to be dragged into court
and i'm ignoring the whole aspect of
like the anonymous component
and um multi-state wallets and
you know with enough resources those
things will come to light you will find
the humans
and those will be the people who are
liable so
that is the case that we will see we
will see that will be the controlling
case law
um unless you can get a statutory
cre uh uh entity created at the state
level
any state let's call call it the united
states right now but like
just the way you can form an llc in
colorado you can form a c
corp in colorado if we can create a
a a state recognized
entity as a dow uh that then affords
that entity the liability protections
that a company would
that would mitigate that sort of uh
that sort of precedent setting case um
and would would you know knit all this
in the butt
i don't think that's going to happen um
we're my firm's kicking around
uh lobbying with uh with
the colorado legislature to see if we
could try to create something like that
but
what i think will cause that is uh
some some big disaster will happen to
some decentralized
uh organization and everybody else will
go oh [ __ ] i need to talk to you
sorry i don't know if i can swear on
this i apologize um
i need to talk to a lawyer um so that
that doesn't happen to me
and so when you think through this this
is fascinating to most people because i
think that they look at these dows and
they say oh it's decentralized
uh one sometimes they're actually not
decentralized but but i think the hope
is that you can actually build
decentralized technology
and so how do you look at the balance
between
uh the promise of the decentralized kind
of autonomous organization
within a legal structure does the legal
structure
kind of uh mitigate or
um you know almost like um
silence the decentralization because now
there is a legal structure there's
lawyers involved
uh there's something to go after or how
does that kind of work if
we fast forward and we say okay uh
there's going to be legal challenges
eventually we're gonna get to this like
state recognized
dow entity uh how do you think that kind
of plays out full well knowing that like
this could change in the future
so yes on on one hand
uh there is the sort of thought that you
could create
the corporate rapping and now there is
something to go after
um but i would argue that
when that doesn't exist we're going back
to that general that gp
kind of connotation um and the example
where it was you and me 50 50
it's actually a little bit worse than
that uh in that it's
we're jointly and severally liable so um
if they can get a hold of both of us
then you and i are each
you know 50 50 whatever our political
ownership is responsible
but if they can only get a hold of me
then they can hold me
100 responsible for both of our actions
so while i can see on one hand while you
know someone
in someone working in the decentralized
space might say well i don't wanna
i don't wanna wrap up my tao in
something that's targetable or that's
you know located in wyoming colorado um
but at the same time
you know if there are citizens in the
united states and
and uh they get that their company gets
targeted whether that's by the
government
or by a civil lawsuit um
they themselves are already the target
and they are completely responsible if
they're the only ones who can be found
um so that
i think that is uh the sort of
um recognition that people don't quite
have yet
and she'll answer can i answer that
question you did
how does pseudo nominate pseudonymity or
anonymity play into this right in terms
of
uh if i'm out there with my real name
and i can be found i'm liable what
happens if i
am using a twitter handle
but you don't actually know who i am or
literally
in a you know kind of and that would be
like a satoshi nakamoto situation or
like a pseudo-anonymous name
or actually just literally anonymous
like nobody knows who
did this but now it's out there is this
something where just like
hey people spend enough money and like
they'll eventually figure it out
is this you could convict like a
pseudo-anonymous person and then if they
ever get uncovered then the conviction
sticks to them like
how does that work so
yeah uh that is a really good question
and um
i'm actually a uh a git coin kernel
mentor for their
uh block two program and we had a big
conversation yesterday uh with
with all the fellows um and the answer
to that
is one you certainly could delay the
inevitable
being pseudonymous or fully uh anonymous
that is that is true um and i want to be
clear that i'm
this is a separate analysis from satoshi
that's that's different
uh and i can go into that why but um
if the u.s government for example
decides that they want to come out to
you
they're going to come after you they're
going to use chain analysis they're
going to use
the nsa they're going to use whatever
they can at their
at their fingertips they will eventually
figure you out unless
you are just a hacker extraordinaire
and you've covered all your tracks um
you know
eventually with enough resources and i
would argue the us government has enough
resources
they will pierce that anonymity
where the sort of delay comes in is when
you then back down from that and you're
looking at civil claims
and you've got uh attorneys who are
you know maybe suing i don't know
something like sushi swap or unit swap
like
the the anonymity that might be there
will certainly pose difficulties
there'll be evidentiary
uh questions um but
ultimately with i think the answer is
with enough resources
pseudonym pseudonymity will be
set aside um it's just a question of
whether or not
you need law enforcement to do that or
you know a well-funded
individual can do that and i think
that's sort of um
up for debate i don't i don't know if
we've got we're anywhere near that yet
um but that's a lot of people will will
argue that
well i'm anonymous nobody knows this or
i'm located in the czech republic and
i've got a company and mauritius like
you know what what's the risk and it's
like
you know that's it's just delaying if
something's going to happen it's going
to happen
you mentioned satoshi nakamoto uh kind
of being a separate case
explain that a little bit so i mean i i
don't think that we're gonna see
the us government figuring out or at
least publicly who
satoshi is um i think that it's
so far back and it's it's uh so
foundational
that and you know bitcoin has been
basically deemed a commodity
by the cftc um
they're more focused on more recent
things so
if someone tried to do a pseudonymous
launch of a new token
uh sec is going to catch that um they're
looking now
i don't think there's any incentive for
them to try to piece together
uh what happened at the sounding of
bitcoin um
and even if they did i'm not sure how
much uh
you know what what would they accomplish
at that point i honestly don't believe
that there would be anything
worth that spend uh of resource um
it's definitely you know the the dd5
stuff
that is clearly uh implicating some of
the
the banks receive acts um things that
would impute uh
the patriot act um we're talking about
billions of dollars
that is where they're going to focus
that is where
the pseudo-anonymous uh founders are
gonna
are gonna be experiencing government
heat
got it and so if we kind of look at
let's say a really kind of
what i would consider a cut and dry
example of where some of this complexity
plays out so
let's say that i build a decentralized
exchange
and that decentralized exchange is
actually decentralized i can't take it
down
even if the government comes and puts a
gun to my head and no one else can so
it's kind of a fully decentralized
um you know censorship resistant
exchange
and then people go on and they start to
trade uh what ends up being
deemed you know illegal securities where
uh whether they are non-accredited
investors
or there was some issue with the actual
securities
uh being offered originally whatever it
is
what is the precedent or how do you
think through
is the founder of that decentralized
exchange
um responsible for what happens
on the exchange uh if let's say the
founder was 18 when they started it
and they put it out in the world and
then at 25 they're like you know what
maybe i don't want to be as
uh you know take on the state and screw
the system and like i want to take it
down but i actually can't take it down
like how does all that play out sure so
um there's no clear answer to that
exactly i will say that we have a fairly
uh good piece of uh data with ether
delta
um you know as a decentralized
as a decentralized exchange but they
were still able to like figure out
who was responsible and that person
still had control and i think control
is a key concern here so if you have a
truly decentralized exchange
and put it up there and you literally
can't control it anymore
you know that is going to
limit the ability of law enforcement to
come after you um it doesn't necessarily
eliminate it and it certainly doesn't
eliminate civil liability everybody
forgets that like
we're not just talking about criminal
sanctions here we're talking about
uh what could a plaintiff's attorney
extract from you um and then most of
these people
if they're gonna you know maybe there's
some few some
truly egalitarian um
and uh high-minded devs who literally do
a fair launch
and have no pre-mine have no tokens
it's just up there but reality most of
these have some kind of hold back from
themselves and that
that hold back the idea that you're
going to get an increase in value based
on what you've held back as far as like
say a governance token
that absolutely brings the securities
laws right back into play
34 act 33 act um and
of course the private securities
litigation uh cause of action
and so if they don't hold back any of
the tokens if they literally
just say i'm gonna make zero economic
benefit from this does that change that
evaluation
i think it does i think it does i mean
if you really could have could point to
that fact pattern
and say you know someone just released
this in the wild
and it's automated and it has they have
no way to
affect change and like that's really key
like no
way to affect change you know some of
these things are kind of out in the wild
but
you get enough of the founders together
they could in theory
tweak stuff you know for and it's not
not like they're doing anything shady
there it's
that they want to be able to fix
something or something because it breaks
but if they don't have that ability yeah
i think that just releasing that
what is an effect basically a piece of
code uh
an amm that just runs um i think you'd
have a very difficult time
coming after somebody like that yeah and
so really what you end up doing is
you're basically putting a balance
between
uh economic benefit and legal liability
right and so if you want
uh no legal liability that means you
should probably take no economic benefit
if you're okay with some legal liability
then you can take economic benefit you
got to figure out where
you know kind of where your priorities
lie or kind of where your risk tolerance
is
yeah and and like you know it might not
just be a specific project analysis like
if you've got a master plan and
over here you've got uh something like
an
nft project and over here you know to
make this nfv project function
you could have this uh this amm that is
totally you know you wanted to run by
itself
if if you could draw the connection
where you need one for the other
uh you certainly um could impute
liability that way
what about like decentralized lending um
that feels to me
like it is uh less obvious the ways that
founders could make mistakes
uh then like let's say an exchange that
traded uh you know illegal securities
like that seems pretty cut and dry to me
uh but when it comes to lending or some
of these other
financial service type uh offerings that
are supposed to be decentralized and
we'll just
make the assumption that they are
decentralized um
is is there things where uh you don't
have a money transmitter license or a
broker-dealer license
or you know kyc aml and you can be held
liable for that stuff
or is it something else that they should
be worried about
so honestly i actually think this is
where we're going to see
the most uh uh flurry of enforcement
and i think it's going to be much much
more serious than a breach of
the 33 act or 34 act both you know
securities law
focus the bank secrecy act is a big deal
it is a big deal the patriot act gives
the government
a lot of power here um and so when you
start i mean you've already heard
janet yellen just you know uh in the
last
week or so two weeks ago saying that
terrorist financing
is is on their radar i mean whether it
is or not that's what they'll say
that is what will be stated as they go
after these platforms and
there are really strict rules around aml
and kyc
for anything financial um thank god
the the fincen stuff was averted that
was a nightmare
um and but but that's that's where we're
headed
so bringing it back to the question
about
liability and control and uh
this decentralized idea if if um
fincen decides that uh they want to go
after one of these things because they
aren't following
proper disclosure for funds and and
people they're going to do that in any
way they can
and i think that we have yet to see what
that will look like but i think a lot of
people are going to be caught
flat-footed
yeah it's fascinating to me that uh
the securities laws and kind of the icos
and and
uh unregistered securities like that
caught everyone's attention from a legal
perspective that's what i wanted to talk
about
what you've kind of done is you're
accelerating or fast forwarding you're
saying no no no like
when somebody applies the patriot act
they can pretty much do anything
and therefore not only do they have more
kind of
legal uh purview but also the penalties
are much higher as well
right so is this something where you
think that um kind of
the the reach uh of the us
government will be global and it doesn't
matter where you are because they'll use
that patriot act
or do you think that u.s citizens have a
different risk profile on the legal side
than let's say people who are not u.s
citizens not living in the united states
well sure so primarily uh on a
first impression u.s citizens are going
to have a far
larger risk file u.s companies are going
to have a far larger risk
but we actually have a precedent here uh
with the
crs the common reporting standards which
was
kind of forced on the world by the u.s
after the passing of the patrol
or around the same time um and you have
a very
clear example of the us government using
its full
force and effectiveness to impute
its way on sovereign nations
um so i think that you know if you're
if you're a team that's all not u.s and
you properly
geofence u.s residents you have a good
argument
you're not subject to u.s law but no one
is actually
geofencing u.s residents not really
um and that is that is like the opening
in the armor that is how
the us government will attempt to assert
itself uh and they will use
uh treaties and they will use
relationships with
other countries to get their way
eventually if they want to
it's a question of wanting no no i will
say there is an overton window here
um and if the overton window shifts
enough
there is a chance that some of these
doom and gloom things that i'm talking
about
kind of get papered over get sort of the
the paradigm shifts and the good example
there is
uh uh uber if you walked into
a law firm in 20 2005 and said
i want to create an app that allows
people to
uh use other people's cars every lawyer
is going to say oh my god you can't do
that
like that there's here are all the
reasons why you can't do that so it's
what we're trained to do and it would
have been good advice at the time
but that's an example of where things
moved quickly enough
and had enough of an impact where you
know those concerns
didn't materialize you know other things
certainly get materialized out of it but
um that is an example of the tech
shifting
over to the window more quickly than the
regulations
can catch up in a way that regulations
will never catch up or could never catch
up
um but that and there will be some of it
and i i i don't know how much of that
there will be
um but it is on the table there will be
there'll be some sort of moment where
certain certain projects
think as big as unit swap might you know
just escape through
it absolutely could happen um but there
will be a lot
of collateral damage for some of the
smaller projects
and is your thought process kind of we
haven't really seen the enforcement in
the d5 world
regardless of what blockchain is being
built on or whatever but like that's
coming
yes yes so um it's definitely coming
they
definitely understand well they have an
idea of what's happening
i think there's very few people
including myself who actually
understands everything but
um yeah it's it's a there are people who
are
paying attention at every level of
government um both you know finance
related
uh counterterrorism related espionage
related just policy
people are paying attention they know
this has happened and i brought up
you know that one client earlier you
know the investigation
started in 2014 arrest happened in 2019.
these things take time and it's hard to
hold that timeline against these
projects that are you know worth
billions of dollars over the course of a
summer
founding founding to billions of dollars
that's that's probably never happened
uh in fact i would feel confident in
saying you know
not going through the traditional
financing right that's never happened um
these are these are startups that are
more valuable than you know companies
that have been around for decades
um so i lost my train of thought sorry
no no i i think that you're you're
nailing it in the sense of
um the enforcement
one takes time you say that a couple
times i think that's dead on i think
two is uh people are paying attention so
the it's like they're going to start
looking at things that are
what they deem to be illegal wrong
whatever and they will come after it
but even on top of that one of the
things that i think i'm hearing you kind
of talk through
is like uh this constant cat and mouse
game right it's like
innovation leaps forward the law catches
up innovation leads forward the law
catches up
and so this isn't so much like this is
an irregular development in the market
this happens over and over and over
again whether it's cannabis crypto or
name your other innovative industry
uh it's just like we're literally just
feeling the pain of going through that
kind of evolution yeah i i would say
it's a little different
when you when you realize that what
we're talking about is money
uh this is it is uh is a fundamental
new ingredient in the sort of innovation
uh
facebook and google you know they
weren't
involved in at the beginning they
weren't involved in money
and money has some connotations around
sovereignty and around power that
i think is drawing more attention
probably correctly i mean that this is
pretty standard
uh when you start to mess with money
supply um so
yes broadly very similar uh
pattern here we've seen in many
industries the one little
change is like the fact that this is a
money focused well i don't want to say
it's money
because we've all known the technology
is available to a lot of things but like
the fact that it's currency sovereign
these are sovereign currencies
um that does change things a little bit
um but i do believe that it'll follow a
similar
sort of catch-up uh pattern
that you described yeah uh before we get
into the rapid fire questions to wrap
up uh i just want to kind of give you
the floor of like what's the
key pieces of like almost like blanket
advice right so not legal advice to
anybody
but just as people want to build in this
industry what are the things that they
should be considering
what should they be doing to make sure
that they're at least positioning
themselves to not
do like really dumb low-hanging fruit
stuff that they can easily avoid
so i i don't want to sound like a
shameless plug here so i won't say talk
to us
uh but talk to a lawyer i i cannot
stress that enough
um the uh the amount of pain
that i have seen happen where people get
a certain point and then involve
someone like me and then you know you
point to a foundational part of their
business model it's like
that's illegal you can't do that i i and
and i say that with the caveat of
everything i just said about the opening
window
and and and uber um there are some
fundamental things that they just
that are i guess there are some some
aspects that if they
talk to a lawyer first they would be
able to uh
more efficiently and effectively address
maybe the bigger issue
uh which does take more of a leap of
faith
but i mean so uh one of our clients uh
you know they they didn't bother to
check whether or not
there was a trademark for the company
they founded and they did an ico
and uh i had to deal with an
old-school trademark attorney and
explain to him that
we couldn't change the token at this
point like it's
it's in beautiful um and we ended up
coming to an agreement but like
you know they burned a ton of money uh
just dealing with a silly little thing
whereas if they had come to a lawyer
you know the first thing would have done
would have been to run a check
for the name um you know it's stuff like
that
uh that i think that people get get your
attorney
get someone legal involved at the
product
uh market fit uh stage and um
you know with the caveat that you know
maybe the whole overarching project is a
little bit outside the lines
but if you can smooth some of the
smaller
obvious things you can devote more time
to the
changing of that overton window with a
big part of it yeah that's a great way
to look at it kind of the big picture in
the small picture
i asked every person the same three
questions that you'll get to ask me one
to finish up
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
yeah so a little bit of a bummer i guess
but uh the age of surveillance
capitalism by
gennady you know
the way that she explains the the data
rendition
um economy and what it has actually
done was mind-blowing to me and it was
i've been telling everybody since i read
it you have to read this
it's super dry it's very difficult to
get through it's one of the hardest
books you've ever read
but it to me it's almost like the
equivalent of uh
das capital uh in marks like just
coming up with an entirely different
view on on economics i mean that's how
fundamentally
uh different it is and how important it
is
and i think everybody everybody should
do this
yeah that's a great suggestion uh second
one's more personal uh this comes from
the folks over at eight sleep
uh they've got this thermoregulation bed
which basically makes it super cold for
you
uh so that you can sleep better um i
used to be like a five six hour sleeper
now i'm like a eight nine hopefully i
can get ten if uh
if i have time uh what's your sleep
schedule are you
a um you know five hour sleeper ten hour
sleeper and somewhere in between
so i am a chronic insomnia evidence
tommyx is about hurt
um so sleep has been one of my uh
primary uh antagonists my entire life
there have been times like when i was
describing getting into um
the crypto space it's certainly been an
advantage um
because i can just go but it's uh it's
not sustainable
i'm constantly uh trying to get better
sleep get more sleep
you know change my sleep cocktail that i
need to take um
it has been a very it's been a lifelong
fight and it has not been a fun one
do you uh sleep on like uh in like a
cold room or on a cold bed or anything
yeah so uh i have a sleep number bed
uh that you can maneuver uh the
uh its angle and
its temperature and it has some other
features that
that help i've also experimented with
binaural beats which
are playing different tones and
different sides of your
of your head to try to change your wave
function and i've actually
seen that work a little bit um you name
it um i've tried it when it comes to
sleeping
i look i've heard a lot of people
obviously asking this question say a lot
of
crazy [ __ ] i've never heard it was a
binaural beat so i know that you're an
expert if that's uh
if that's one of the things that you've
tried uh
third question is a little bit more fun
aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer i think statistically
mathematically
uh you got to be a believer i do not
believe that we've been visited
and i'm not convinced that we ever will
make contact given
the the size of space and the time uh
changes that are involved you know
everything we see is billions of years
old already but yes i do not believe we
are alone
in the universe they certainly haven't
visited us though
yeah i think that's kind of uh where i
end up it's like i don't think little
green men have showed up
but uh but they got to be out there
somewhere uh or at least i'd like to
think so it makes sense
uh what's the one question you have for
me to uh to finish up
um so yeah uh so so the deeper that i
i've gone to blockchain and crypto and
more
both personally and professionally and
the the more adoption i see the stronger
my belief in all this
goes um and
as those beliefs get more and more
ingrained it sort of
uh has skewed my my media and my news
consumption
um you know i basically stopped
listening to music i listened to like
podcasts like yours like hidden forces
you all asked that allocation podcast um
and for the most part the hosts of the
show and the guests
all kind of just reinforce those beliefs
uh so much so that i get these points
where i'm i'm i go through like
intense periods of uh like self-doubt
and wondering if i'm in an echo chamber
i think at one point i was asking
friends on my telegram chats
if they had any uh uh like
mmt uh pro mmt podcast or anti-big
bitcoin uh things i could read um
because i was just
worried that i'm just deep in this echo
chamber and kind of
plays into the surveillance capitals and
what you get fat and stuff
and i got to imagine that for you that
this this this has got to be a
an order of magnitude larger issue being
with all of your evangelicalism
and uh you know bitcoin uh
you know bringing it to the masses and
who you talk to
so that was a really long build up but
my question is uh
how do you check to see if you're in an
echo chamber
and as a corollary is there anyone that
you've had on the show
that has has challenged or changed
uh your world view from that echo
yeah so i think that um there's two
things i'm kind of checking
right so one is i've got some like very
specific things that i think through
uh so like one market adoption two
self-inflicted wound
uh in terms of code being introduced to
the blockchain uh
of bitcoin uh three is price
uh four is certain um kind of milestones
of future
uh institutional adoption corporate
adoption central bank adoption like
there's a couple of things that um i
watch and if something was to happen i
would definitely like oh wait a second
that's a red flag kind of like if you
had like a dashboard an alert one
offices something's wrong
right and then you kind of go
investigate it um so that's kind of just
on a passive basis
uh didn't i actually enjoy um
kind of going and talking to people so
i'm less of somebody who's like
let me go read the latest you know hit
piece on bitcoin or whatever it's more
so like if somebody disagrees i want to
go talk to them
and i want to understand why they think
and then uh you know my wife would tell
you that
my absolute favorite thing to do uh and
i've got to be careful i got to warn
people more often than
just inviting them for dinner i like to
bring them for dinner
uh and then just go to like intellectual
war with people right and it's just like
what do you believe here's what i
believe and like let's just have it out
um and uh yeah they can get pretty
spirited
uh but also i learned an incredible
amount during these and
hopefully the other person does as well
but what's so fascinating to me
is you very quickly understand not just
what somebody believes
but how deep their conviction and what
they believe that's right and i think
that the
the level of conviction especially when
you're talking to you know very
intelligent people
uh is almost just as important as what
they're saying so it's like you know
believing something's great believing
something and then having deep
conviction is even better
um and so i think that that's kind of
how i really look through it in terms of
people coming on the podcast
uh in the beginning i had lots and lots
of people i think a lot of the people
who kind of question bitcoin now don't
really come on they all hide
what they'll say is something to the
effect of like oh i don't know that much
right but they they know that oh i don't
understand it it's like
it's a five-page eight-page wait paper
how do you not understand it i know
you're smart
yeah well what they'll do is look on the
podcast because i don't really want to
talk about this like i don't really
understand that much
i i know that you're anti-bitcoin which
is by the way it's fine it's a great
position to have if that's what you
believe
you know i think you're wrong but that's
fine uh but it's always funny like they
don't want to actually have the debate
uh
especially not in a recorded situation
um and the last thing i would say
is uh i i try to get out of
the like bitcoin anti-bitcoin like
that's too
much of a macro thing and i think that
that's like
uh a little bit misleading because
actually i i
have yet to meet somebody who just like
writes off the entire system
right there somebody may say hey look i
understand the technology and i think
the technology is real but i don't think
it's going to be successful because i
think the government will crack down on
it and so like
that's what i want to debate i want to
debate the micro issue right it's like
okay let's talk about government
intervention and government
regulation of this asset of the players
in the industry that type of stuff
and so to me it's it's more so like the
more you understand the more
nuanced conversation you want to have if
you don't understand it that well you
just want to debate it at a high level
like should i buy bitcoin or should i
not
right i'm much more interested in kind
of the nuance micro level
um but uh you know as with all of these
things and probably some level of
confirmation bias like
the more micro you want to talk about
the harder it is to find you know
somebody who disagrees because in order
to understand the micro you've got to
have gone pretty far down the uh the
rabbit hole which means that you
probably believe
um so uh that's kind of how i think
about it
gotcha interesting um
cool uh i actually i i have to say i'm a
little disappointed
uh i i was hoping you were gonna ask at
some point
um the used to ask everybody on
the show almost like uh what regulation
they would change
i assumed i would get a regulation
question let's hear it i would love to
hear if you've got a regulation that you
would change
so i have three uh oh okay that's
amazing
first and foremost end schedule one uh
designation of substances is the single
most uh anti-science piece of
legislation that has ever been
put into uh effect it has killed people
not the war on drugs
that's a separate analysis um all the
good that can be done with
uh hallucinogens and pathogens is
completely
uneven able to study is a travesty i
actually wrote an article
uh about um the entitled schedule one
is a crime against humanity um so that's
that's first and foremost that has been
both mine and my firm's primary uh
thesis for a while but then
more into the spirit of the podcast uh i
would
completely revamp the accreditation
standards for accredited investors it
would no longer be
a finance base a wealth-based uh
criteria you have to take some sort of
you know simple test
uh and when people talk about
democratizing finance i think
that is where you have to start because
it's just not fair
and just because you're rich doesn't
mean you're smart uh and then
lastly getting near and dear to all of
our our hearts would be to normalize the
tax treatment of
crypto i it's like uh we're brothers
uh i like all three of those i did
i didn't hear a single thing in there
that i thought was crazy actually that
was pretty common sense
uh so the fact that none of that's
happened yet seems like uh maybe we need
some more people
with common sense and uh and the
regulatory and legislative parties
well you know it's going to happen time
is inevitable and
people who were crypto native are going
to be in power in
you know probably starting in real
numbers in 10 years
uh hopefully it doesn't take that long
um but uh
you'll see the the change in the guard i
think
i think you are uh you're definitely
right there my friend where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find uh
more um if they want to uh kind of reach
out to you guys for some legal services
sure so uh the rodmanlawgroup.com is our
website uh
phone number is on there uh info rodman
law group.com is the
email and then we're on twitter at
rodman law
and uh we're available awesome you guys
do fantastic work i really appreciate
you coming on here
uh i find it fascinating a lot of the
the legal analysis and kind of
uh this legal battle frankly that's
going to play out in the decentralized
world so
hopefully people uh won this peak their
interest but also two
uh they understand like hey look if
you're gonna go play in this world make
sure you get a good lawyer so i
thank you so much and watch this again
in the future
yeah absolutely i'd love to come back on
and talk anytime
this was fantastic